ahora llegaron las lluvias
tan solo tres días después del terremoto
de magnitud 7,2 que causó devastación al
sur de haití los residentes locales se
enfrentan a otro desafío encontrar
lugares seguros para protegerse de las
intensas precipitaciones y las
inundaciones tras el paso de la tormenta
tropical kreis
[Aplausos]
la lluvia nos cayó encima dormimos
sentados sencillas nadie ha venido a
ayudarnos no tenemos lonas dormimos aquí
sentados no quiero ir a casa estoy en
manos de dios
centenares de personas pasan día y noche
bajo carpas en espacios abiertos algunos
por temor a que las réplicas del
terremoto puedan colapsar sus hogares
otros porque ya no tienen a donde ir
el terremoto ocurrió el sábado alrededor
de las 8 32 am vinimos aquí pero
enfrentamos grandes dificultades ya que
mucha gente no tiene un lugar para
dormir nuestras casas están destruidas o
inundadas no please do a paseo a 10 1
las lluvias complican las labores de
rescate y la atención a los heridos que
se da bajo tiendas improvisadas
naciones unidas afirmó quedar a ocho
millones de dólares para apoyar la
respuesta humanitaria este dinero
proporcionará ayuda esencial como
atención médica agua potable y albergue
de emergencia y saneamiento para las
personas afectadas por el desastre el
primer ministro ariel entró y prometió
acelerar la gestión de las ayudas
internacionales tras la experiencia del
terremoto de 2010 donde el manejo de los
recursos
se vio reflejado en la reconstrucción se
estima que esta vez unas 37 mil casas
resultaron destruidas muchas
edificaciones no han sido registradas
por lo que se espera que la cifra de
muertos siga en aumento